all right how's it going koa I got a
question for you what is your definition
of languages evolved over time if I
wrote this message to meld it to the
1960s it would be dismissed as nonsense
like any language what is considered
music is also constantly changing when
the Ramones released their debut album
in 1976 parents hated it and radio
stations wouldn't play it but three
decades later their music was selling
Diet Pepsi they have always been
musicians and composers that push the
edges of what we call music in the early
20th century some composers began to
reject conventional ideas of harmony and
tonality and no composer did this more
boldly than Arnold Schoenberg who wrote
music that was so against the times that
audiences would often brew laughs and
heckle at his performances imagine it's
the 1920s your ears are probably more
accustomed to the sounds of composers
such as Mozart
then you hear in performance of
Schaumburg sweet for piano opus 25 to
most audiences it sounded like random
chaos but what was your burg doing opus
25 was actually the first piece composed
entirely using the twelve-tone technique
which is a compositional approach that
Schoenberg invented using this technique
you order the 12 tones of the chromatic
scale in a particular order called a
tone row so here's an example of a tone
row the idea is to make sure that all 12
tones are equally emphasised this
creates a sort of democracy where tones
don't relate to a center like this the
sea clearly has more weight over the
other notes if tone row doesn't have
this I ended on C but the whole phrase
doesn't feel like it's in C major shirne
Berg's rigid ideas of a tonality never
caught on with widespread audience but
artists from other musical backgrounds
would go on to explore similar methods
later in the twentieth century most
notably in jazz in 1961 the Bill Evans
trio recorded a now legendary live jazz
album called Sunday at the Village
Vanguard
[Music]
you hear those traditional ideas of
harmony and core progressions now check
out this excerpt from a free jazz an
album released that same year by
saxophonist Ornette Coleman this is one
of the first albums to usher in free
jazz a movement that like Schoenberg
challenged traditional ideas of tonality
the goal of artists like Coleman wasn't
necessarily to give each tone equal
emphasis but rather to drop all the
rules so they could express themselves
as freely as possible you can hear it in
the works of artists like Cecil Taylor
Albert Ayler and even John Coltrane soon
after free jazz took off in the 1960s
three sisters from New Hampshire also
began making music that challenged
traditional ideas of tonality and
harmony with their three-piece band
called
the Shaggs but unlike coal train or
Schoenberg who were pushing music from
within established music scenes the
Shaggs were definitely pushing from the
outside
[Music]
someone thinks the Shaggs are a bunch of
no-talent hillbillies I understand that
shacks music doesn't reach out the way
that conventional pop reaches out and
tries to you know grab you with a hook
the Shaggs kind of exists in a little
bit of a bubble and you kind of get
inside that bubble and that I think
applies to the best outside of music it
pulls you into something really unusual
and that's one of the adventures of
outsider music that I that I really love
if you don't like it ignore it don't
listen to me it's okay
one of the most famous fans of outside
of music was David Bowie who based his
Ziggy Stardust alter-ego in part on an
outsider musician named legendary
Stardust cowboy while the bulk of
outside of music never ventures beyond
open mics and the record collections of
a few dedicated fans legendary Stardust
Cowboys music has actually been played
in space aboard Skylab the American
space station launched in 1973 one of
the duties in Mission Control everyday
was to wake the crew up in the morning
and usually played nice stuff like wake
up sunshine or something like that and I
said I've got this record a nominal
guaranteed wake up today legendary
service Cowboys
it's fine very very sore that Cowboys
yes I probably almost included the
legend like that he can't play what
happens when a composer wants to make a
sound that can't be created by a
traditional instrument you make your own
that's what American composer hairy
parched
[Music]
parch was interested in micro tonality
and a 12 tone octave just wasn't enough
he composed using 43 tones within the
traditional octave and created
instruments out of everything from old
airplane parts to liquor bottles so that
he could play his compositions but no
composer more boldly challenged
traditional ideas of music and Confused
audiences in the process than John Cage
an American whom Arnold Schoenberg
described as not a composer but an
inventor of genius Cage knew how to play
and compose for traditional instruments
but he's most famous for writing
compositions that featured sounds
generated from everyday objects
[Music]
he also pioneered the idea of the
prepared piano a piano that's been
temporarily altered to produce exotic
and percussive sounds by placing objects
like screws wood and rubber between the
strings cage left many decisions of the
chance to arrange his imaginary
landscape number four which calls for 24
performers to turn 12 radios to certain
volumes and stations at specific times
cage use an ancient Chinese divination
system called the Yi Jing to decide what
to come next
although cage was making music with
radios and definitely not for the radio
his work has influenced many well-known
musicians John Cale of The Velvet
Underground was a student of cage and
Radiohead's
Thom Yorke called him one of his
all-time art heroes let's find a
template that is completely non musical
and then apply our musical elements into
it a sentence from the English language
or like a shape it has to be like a
dodecagon ok let's use this word sound
you the name sounds yes I feel like s
sounds like this oh why don't you take
sound so I'll take feel you and yeah and
and it's and I aren't sure how I'm
interpreting it until after and you do
the same okay you can interpret it
because it looks this way or it sounds
tight what's do it
[Music]
I'm more desensitized to certain types
of harmony and certain types of textures
the older I get
once I'm exposed to this type of
dissonance let's talk about dissonance
over I get used to that and then the
next time I hear it it's no longer as
jarring so Curie yeah kind of like food
you know when you're a kid the older you
get the more exposed you are two
different types of food I mean I
remember when I was a kid I loved the
smell of coffee because it was sweet but
as soon as I tasted it I thought this
isn't drinkable this isn't edible you
acquire a taste for it and then it
changes that's probably how a lot of
fans of outside of music became fans
because when you first hear this like
wait what I don't know if anybody falls
in love at the first sound where do you
draw the line between music and not
music let us know in the comments and
please subscribe
[Music]